[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact a
home intruder thought that a house
occupied by a lone 82 year old woman in
Rochester New York would be an easy
target he chose poorly when at at 11:00
p.m. on November 24 2009 teen the
would-be attacker knocked down the door
of Willie Brown he received the surprise
of his life as the man entered her home
he was expecting he'd rough up the old
lady intimidate her into handing over
any nearby cash and valuables he could
use this then for his drug habit instead
as he walked down the dark hall he was
knocked to the ground with a table and
then clobbered several more times with
the same then the old woman began to
jump on him and successively beat him
with a heavy shampoo bottle and a
broomstick you see the ATT old woman
Willie Brown is a championship
bodybuilder who can still deadlift 225
pounds and she works out at the local
YMCA every day when the police arrived
the intruder was still on the ground
bloodied and bruised after arresting the
assailant the police and paramedics
asked if they could have selfies with
Willie who said the criminal just picked
the wrong house you know the Bible says
that there's been a long ongoing battle
between a dragon and a woman who might
seem helpless but guess who
in the end and stay with his friends
we're gonna learn more on this edition
of Bible answers live you're listening
to Bible answers live accurate and
practical answers to your Bible
questions welcome listening friends the
Bible answer is live and if you've got a
Bible question then pick up your phone
give us a call we have lines open the
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 God says
and in addition we're also streaming
this right now on Facebook that would be
the amazing facts Facebook page and the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page and this is
the dawn of a new program lines are open
if you have Bible questions pick up the
phone give us a call great opportunity
to get your question on tonight's
program it's also not a bad time to text
your friends and say hey you can watch
or listen the Bible answers live right
now and send in your Bible question
I'm Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
good evening friends and pass the bag as
we always do let's stop with the word of
Prayer
dear father again we thank you that we
can open up your word and study together
this evening we want to ask your
blessing upon this program be with the
many listed and listeners scattered
across the country and even in different
countries leaders a clear understanding
of your word for we ask this in Jesus
name Amen amen oh pastor you open the
program talking about a surprised thief
when he discovered that this old lady 82
years of age was not just an easy
pushover but she actually got the better
on him yeah it wasn't at all prepared
and she's not that tall either but I
guess she's extremely tough and you know
when when someone invades your home you
know the adrenaline release and and yeah
he met the surprise of his life but it
made me think how often you know God
turns the tables and in particular
there's a story that runs all the way
through the Bible of a battle between a
woman in the dragon and it starts in
Genesis chapter 3 verse 15 where you see
that there is this serpent there's
dragon that is tempting the woman Eve
and you can track this battle all the
way through the Bible until you get to
Revelation chapter 12 and then other
passages in the remainder of Revelation
where you talk about the dragon is
wanting to destroy the woman the dragon
persecutes the woman but in the end the
woman is enthroned and rescued and the
dragon is cast into the lake of fire and
so there's a big turning of the tables
that takes place maybe some of our
friends would like to know something
about where we are right now in the
stream of prophecy when it comes to
Revelation the dragon in the woman and
we have a free offer that will help you
understand that free offer today is one
of the amazing facts study guides and
it's got an intriguing title it's called
the Bride of Christ and will be a plea
sense to anyone who calls and asks the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
our resource phone line and we won't
encourage you to answer the study guide
it's called the Bride of Christ and if
you have a Bible question a phone line
here to the studio is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven eight
hundred four sixty three seventy to
ninety seven our first call of this
evening is from New York we have Anthony
Anthony welcome to Bible answers live
Anthony you're on the air you might have
your mute on Anthony are you there
Anthony from New York
I hear me now yes now we hear you we did
hear you and you just disappeared I
don't know what happened tell you what
Anthony call us back and we'll move you
to the top of the list here in the
meantime we better go to another caller
we've got Joe listening in North
Carolina Joel welcome to the program hi
pastor Doug hi Pastor Ross hi Joel
thanks for calling my son wants to know
is it okay for curses to play video
games with violets above that's a good
question you know in every in every
situation a Christian ultimately is a
follower of Christ and you want to ask
the question what would Jesus do now I
just want to be clear I remember I was
trying to learn how to tie
and there was a computer program that
tried to teach you to type with a game
and so you could technically call it a
computer game and but it was edifying
I'm learning something valuable and so I
think it was pretty harmless there's a
few issues one is you don't want
violence in your mind
pastor Raphael look up and it says in
Psalms I will set no evil thing before
my eyes
joe-joe I think also has a similar
statement so you don't want to behold
evil whatsoever things are good holy
pure those are the things were to think
on Paul tells us and so there's that
aspect then there's the aspect of
wasting time now I'll make a public
confession which is supposed to be good
for the soul and bad for the reputation
years ago when pac-man came out I
started playing pac-man on one of those
little home computers probably an
innocent game but man you can spend
hours doing that and get all worked up
and get upset if you don't win and and I
pretty soon realized man I'm just
wasting time playing this game so
there's the issue of we got so much
probationary time during this life to
not only serve God but help other people
find God it's okay to maybe have a
little time of diversion if it's
innocent diversion but you don't want to
waste endless hours I still a playing
chess and I'm not condemning anyone that
does but it took hours and hours and I
thought this is really how I want to
spend so much of my time so you know I
don't think Christians should be holding
the violence mm-hmm by playing games
where you're shooting and killing what
was that there was a game Grand Theft
Auto and a young man watched that game
so often that he actually went out and
he killed some policemen and stole their
cars and he said the same things when he
was arrested that they said same exact
script he repeated that was in the game
and so if someone says these games do
not influence people I would have to
respectfully disagree
you know the verse you're referring to
pass sadecki Psalm 101 verse 3 where it
says I will set nothing wicked before my
eyes and I think that it's good counsel
for every person
thank you for your coal I next coal I
think we got Anthony back in New York
Anthony welcome to the program thank
t'me you there yes can you hear me okay
yes we can get you okay create sorry for
the technical difficulties so my
question is based on second Peter
chapter 3 verse 10 and I go ahead and
read it okay it says no I've got it here
if you want me to read it okay yeah
that's fine but the day of the Lord will
come as a thief in the night in which
the heavens will pass away with a great
noise and the elements will melt with
fervent heat and both the earth and the
works that are in it will be burned up
yes and then even verse 12 it says
looking for and hasting unto the coming
of the day of God wherein the heavens
being on fire shall be dissolved and the
elements shall melt with fervent heat so
I my question is well first I completely
understand the whole coming as a thief
in the night and I understand how we
should be living and you know in
preparation for the coming since we
don't know when it will be is second
coming but it seems like being that this
verse is clearly talking about the
second of what I assume to be the day of
the Lord being his second coming it says
that the elements will burn up and you
know the heavens and everything will
burn up on that day of his second coming
I was just wondering how did that align
with our understanding of the earth
being set on fire at the end of the
millennium when it says on the day of
the Lord
yeah technically there's two fires you
do have a fire that burns when the Lord
does come and it says the wicked and it
where is it in Thessalonians they're
destroyed by the brightness of his
coming
there's a burning that happens when
Jesus comes and were caught up to meet
him in the air and then at the end of
the 1,000 years following the judgment
when the wicked are cast into the lake
of fire God then basically incinerates
the existing world outside of the New
Jerusalem and the
and the devil is cast into this lake of
fire and then God on the ashes of this
purified planet creates a new heaven and
a new earth I think the verse referring
to his second Thessalonians 2 verse 8 it
says and then the lawless one will be
revealed whom the Lord will consume with
the breath of his mouth and destroy with
the brightness of his coming
hmm and is an Isaiah ya know with fire
and with my sword I will plead with all
flesh and speaks about the second coming
I'm sorry go ahead
ya know and that makes perfect sense I
do understand that now but um that was
another thing I actually have another
question for another time but if you
don't if you have time um just when it
says that wicked it seems to be
referring to the man of sin the the
Antichrist himself but is that are we
going to are we to understand that
that's him and all of his followers all
those that follow after him as well that
wicked yeah you know it's definitely
talking about the Antichrist power but
we also find other passage in Scripture
which talk about the wicked that are on
the earth destroyed from one end of even
to the other they're not buried and
that's not only talking about of course
the Antichrist power but all of those
who are on his side they are destroyed
to the brightness of Christ's coming now
we have a lesson we can send Anthony on
the second coming that talks about that
that's right and we'll be able to send
this to anyone wanting to learn more
about the second coming it's called the
ultimate deliverance and the number to
call for that is 883 five six seven four
seven and again as for the book called
the ultimate deliverance it's all about
the second coming of Christ our next
call is James thanks for calling Anthony
we got James listening in Minnesota
James welcome to the program
hello pastors my question is in Luke
chapter 17 and Matthew 24 there's a
statement it seems like a riddle where
Jesus asked what will be the sign of his
coming and he goes through and lists all
the different signs that would culminate
with the end and then he says and Jesus
answers at the end and says wherever the
carcass is or corpse
there were the Eagles be gathered
together what do you think the corpses
well I think that you've got you know of
course the literal understanding of this
which means that in the time of the
judgment the the wicked are gonna be
destroyed and you read in Revelation it
talks about this feast of the birds and
at the second coming the slain of the
Lord and we forget if it's in Jeremiah
they covered the earth from one end to
another and they will not be lamented or
buried there's a time where the slain of
the Lord are destroyed by the brightness
of his coming and this ties in with our
last question and it's it's saying
wherever the body is that's where the
Eagles come now Jesus was also talking
about the destruction of Jerusalem when
he answered this question and it's
interesting that the Roman power is
often prophesied as an eagle and an
eagle was the emblem of ancient Rome
they used to have on their standards and
a Rome was used as a judgment on ancient
Israel back in the days of Christ when
the nation was conquered and the temple
was burned and so because of the
disobedience of the people in general
then judgment came on them and so I
think there's a double meaning here
because Jesus is answering two questions
so go ahead James remember that yeah in
Luke 17 in verse 36 um is dealing with
the two men in the field one shall be
taken and the literal word means as like
a captive and the other left sets set
free by accepting the mark of the beast
and then they asked him specifically
where will this hat or you know when
will this happen that's in Luke 17
and that's when he answers wherever the
body corpses so this is an endtime
prophecy also so could it be that this
is connected to the fact that the
Jesuits call them
selves a corpse and you know the first
Jesuit Pope is in Rome right now you
know I'd never I'd never really looked
at that verse that way to be honest with
you I think in Luke where he's talking
about and the disciples say we're in
other words where are they taken and he
says wherever the body is that's where
the Eagles are keep in mind it also says
in Matthew and in Luke Jesus said his
second coming is like the days of Noah
when the flood came and took them all
away the ones who were taken away by the
flood were those who were slain by the
judgment and following the flood you
know there were probably a lot of
bloated bodies and and hey you you'd
have birds of carrion so I I think that
Jesus is using that imagery there I
don't think he's really talking about
Rome in this particular case but I thank
you James we're gonna probably have to
move on to another caller hope that
helps a little we've got Tom listening
in Oklahoma Tom welcome to the program
well how are y'all this evening very
good how are you just great just great
my question is saved by grace through
faith how that works well grace is
unmerited favor and that favor that God
gives us comes first all in the form of
His mercy when we believe that Jesus
dies in our place our faith in his
sacrifice in our place that moves us and
that God is willing to freely forgive us
he offers us His grace it's like the
thief on the cross he turns to Jesus in
his dying hour and he said Lord remember
me when you come into your kingdom he
said he's not saying lord I have been a
good person or I deserve to be forgiven
or I've earned it he's looking for mercy
he's looking for the grace of God now
grace is not just the forgiveness that
God offers out of his goodness that we
received by faith grace is also a power
that God gives us
because if grace only forgives us but it
doesn't empower us to be different then
we're back in the same boat again so
God's grace he gives us grace to also
follow him just like he gives us grace
to be forgiven from judgment but it's
the goodness of God yet anything dad
yeah you know Tom we do have a book that
I'm just looking at right here and we'll
be happy to send it to you it's called
the riches of His grace and it's all
about the grace of God helping us
understand what it is and how God wants
to give it to those who ask for it and
put their faith in Him so we'd encourage
you to call and ask for that the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and
again just ask for the book that's
called the riches of His grace and we'll
be happy to send this to you Tom or
anyone that's listening out there
encourage you to call this is a very
good book and I think you'll be blessed
by reading it
we've got Esther listening from
California Esther welcome to the program
thank you pastors I have a friend that
has three beautiful little boys and one
of them actually loves all the horror
movie characters Freddy Krueger Chucky
all of those horrible things and we have
a lot of the toys figurines games
everything that child is always getting
sick how can I advise my friend or where
can i guide her that I don't think
having those dark characters in her home
are good for her children I think maybe
that's why the child's always getting
sick you know I it concerns me that a
parent would even let their child watch
it so they would become acquainted with
the characters and then want the
figurines but I would agree that that's
really troubling because that would put
a lot of ghoulish horrific images in a
child's mind you know I would just pray
that God gives you wisdom and the right
words to talk to your friend and if she
believes in God and then she believes if
there's a God and if she believes the
Bible there's also a devil and you know
we are changed by what we behold
if if kids are beholding heroes and
villains and images of death and murder
I would think that that would not be
that would bode badly for their mental
and physical health and their spiritual
health and so you know maybe you could
just reason with her and you know if she
if she's open to spiritual logic it
would seem like that would be a very
obvious truth that any kind of believer
would accept you know I'm thinking of a
verse that maybe you can share with your
friend Ephesians chapter 5 verse 11 it
says and have no fellowship with the
unfruitful works of darkness I think
that's especially true when it comes to
raising children we don't want to expose
them to Satan's influence and we don't
want to open up the door to any evil
spirits or influences in our home so
correct that's a good advice to give
thank you for your call we got Fritz
listening in Orlando Fritz welcome to
the program thank you Pastor Dan Pastor
John my question is regarding 1st Peter
chapter 3 verses 18 to 21 yesterday we
were having a Bible discussion and those
passages came up and we got a little
confused about the main idea of being
country here especially verse 19 when he
talks about Jesus making proclamation to
the imprisoned spirits we were kind of
confused as to what spirits - I'm glad
you called that that is a difficult
verse but I think it can be easily
understood by just comparing a few
verses let me read it for friends that
are driving down the road for christ
also suffered once for sins the just for
the unjust that he might bring us to God
being put to death in the flesh but made
alive by the spirit now the subject here
is the spirit who made Christ alive by
whom the Spirit he went and preached to
the spirits and the spirits here is
small as that means people individuals
in prison who were formally disobedient
when once the divine long-suffering
waited in the days of Noah so he's
talking about a long-suffering of
patience when the spirit is preaching to
people in the days of Noah
that is referring to Genesis chapter 6
verse 3 where God said my spirit will
not always strive with man his days are
a hundred and twenty years well that's
long-suffering 120 years so for a
hundred and twenty years God strove the
same spirit that rose Jesus is the same
spirit through which God pleaded with a
lost to those people who were imprisoned
by sin back in the days of Noah this is
what Peter's talking about so it's not
saying that Jesus when he died didn't
really die that he went to hell and he
preached and gave people a second chance
the bible does not teach once you die
you get another chance to hear the
gospel it's the Living Dead get to hear
the gospel that's appointed unto man
once to die after that the judgment it
doesn't say after you die then you hear
some more sermons so if people
misunderstand this verse it leads to
some bad theology I hope that helps a
little bit you know pastor Russ we get
this question to be nice to probably
write a little booklet or have a
pamphlet on it we can offer people
because bread read on the surface it can
be confusing alright well thank you for
your coal Fritz we've got time for one
more caller before our break is Sandra
listening in Florida Sandra welcome to
the program hi hi doctor I'm pastor Doug
tester Ross I have a curious question I
don't know that it's that it's a serious
important question but I've heard two
things one that Jesus was nailed through
the palm of the hand and another time I
heard through the wrist and I thought if
there was scripture for that and that he
was nailed on the tree being one tree
not a cross with both hands up over his
head nailed together yes alright good
question now first of all was Jesus with
a nails placed in the hand or in the
wrists the Romans crucified hundreds of
thousands of people and they've done
some excavations and through artwork and
and some reports it could have been the
hand it could have been the wrist the
guards who are in charge
as freedom the idea was you pin him up
now I know my Jehovah Witness friends
say they make a big deal they're very
concerned that Jesus didn't die on a
cross with a cross beam but he died on a
stake where his hands were above his
head Jesus in particular I believe did
die on a cross because there's at verse
when Jesus said to Peter when I think
it's gone John chapter 21 he said when
you are young you girded yourself and
went where you wanted to go but when you
are old another will gird you and you
will stretch forth your hands stretching
forth your hands in the Greek there
would have meant either you stretch them
out in front of you or to the sides not
up and so Christ we believe spread out
his hands even though you know the very
ancient artwork has the the form of a
cross that Jesus died on a cross it's
not a Salvation issue I'm surprised that
you know one church would make a big
deal out of it quite frankly I believe
that there were some Roman soldiers that
crucified they used trees they did not
have fine lumber so they called it a
tree I think Peter and in Acts chapter 3
I think he says Christ who you hung on
the tree and the Bible says cursed is
everyone that is hung on a tree well it
doesn't mean the tree was a stake
sometimes they would just whack down a
tree and they tied two beams together it
would be a cross sometimes they did it
in the form of a tea sometimes the tree
might still have natural branches
attached when they cut it down and and
so I think we've got a cookie cutter
idea of what a crucifixion looked like
and that they did them all the same they
were pretty crude and brutal and they
probably had some variation to it but
everything we know historically Jesus
died on what we would call a cross with
his hand stretched outward says one
thief was on his right and one thief was
on his left and and so I don't know if
that helps a little bit Sandra did that
make sense yes the handle the wrist I
thought there was a scripture that
suggested that he wanted someone to look
look or feel the
wound in his hand he did when he rose
from the dead he told Thomas he said
don't be doubtful but believing he's to
thrust your your hand you're into my the
the scars in my hands now the word he
and there in Greek could include the
wrists I actually I was in the
Philippines and they actually reenact
crucifixions there and I was there one
Easter when they reenacted a crucifixion
and contrary to rumors people are heard
off you get crucified crucified through
the palms of the hand it won't hold up
the body that is totally fall assess it
will hold up the body and I saw it
firsthand it was kind of a horrific
thing but yeah it could have been
through the hand it could have been
through the wrist that would both
qualify as the hand and as I said the
Romans were they weren't real specific
sometimes they lop they put one foot on
top of another and drive a nail
sometimes they turn the foot sideways
and did it through the Achilles tendon
to accentuate the suffering and it was
different every time all we know is he
suffered for us and I'm so thankful he
did don't go away friends we're coming
back with more of your Bible questions
in just a moment
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stance apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers seek his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com you're
listening to Bible answers live where
every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273
my name is John Ross and we're gonna go
to Olivia he's listening in Washington
Olivia welcome to the program hi thank
you yes hi Olivia how can we help you
today my question is is it wrong for
women to baptize alright great question
now when we ask a question we've got to
get our answers from the Bible in the
Bible it tells us that men were the
priests and the priests would officiate
at two or three sacred functions only
men in the Bible offered sacrifice only
men were ordained as priests
it was only the men who would baptize
there's no example in the Bible of a
woman performing a baptism and I think
that you know marriage would come under
that same category as another sacred
function of a pastor or a priest and
that it would it's universally performed
by the men the men were called to be the
priests leaders in their family now
women were also involved in spiritual
ministry you had the priests and the
wives of the priests all took care of
the temple together but their functions
were different talking about in the Old
Testament now
and the men would always offer the
sacrifice the women took care of the the
tapestries and the fabric of the
buildings and the garments for the
priests and so God through the history
of the Bible he has set aside different
roles for men and women and historically
and biblically the men were always the
ones who performed the sacred offices
such as marriage communion baptism so I
hope that helps a little Olivia and I do
have a free book if you'd like that
talks about that
it's called women in ministry God wants
men and women to be involved in serving
him but there are distinctions in some
of the roles if you'd like to receive a
free copy of the book called woman in
ministry the number to call is 808 three
five six seven four seven that of course
is a resource phone line call and ask
for the book on woman in ministry and
we'll be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks we've got mark listening
in Michigan mark welcome to the program
hello I take my call I have a question
about prophecy in Daniel basically
talking about the RAM and the goat the
two horns the horns is the question I
have basically I guess from what I
understand with the study that the the
two horns was Mito the Medes and the
Persians with the goat the the prominent
horn was Alexander the Great for Greece
correct and I guess I don't know if it
broke up into four notable ones yeah yes
it says that but the question I had is
in Revelation when they're talking about
the Beast that comes up out of the sea
it has seven heads and ten horns and
when I understand you know the Roman
Empire broke up and three were
superseded I'm going to the lamb it has
two horns and for my understand that
comes from the earth and is implied that
it's America or United States but the
two horns have never been brought up as
to what where are those two horns I I've
been hearing
candidated States or the Senate and the
Congress or something like that but in
consistency with all the other kingdoms
the horns would be two prominent leaders
or two sections of the government
wouldn't yeah one of the things that you
notice it's different about this is the
and you're on the right track the the
first beast with ten horns is very much
like the beast in Daniel let's get ten
horns and in Revelation 12 you got this
dragon with seven heads and ten horns
but there are no crowns on the horns of
the lamb like beasts
and by the way friends were listening
we're reading now revelation 13:11 this
is the second of two beasts that
implement the mark of the beast from
revelation 13 everyone talks about the
Beast there's technically two beasts in
Revelation 13 second beast is the United
States of America starts out as a lamb
but ends up miss applying its power and
it speaks like a dragon the two horns
I've always understood represent the two
strengths that made America great which
were to have a church without a pope and
to have a government without a king it
was the freedom of the separation of
church and state the freedom of religion
and the freedom of self-rule mm-hmm and
again as you mentioned pastor like the
first beast in Revelation chapter 13 and
I believe it's verse 1 talks about the
10 horns on its head and then it
specifically says in verse 1 and on the
horns 10 crowns so this would be a
monarchy and it refers to the division
of Western Europe now many of the
nations of course on the democratic
system but when they formed it was
clearly a monarchy but this new power
that arises in Revelation chapter 13
verse 11 is different in that it comes
from the earth it has two horns like a
lamb so what are the two governing
principles upon which the United States
is based religious freedom and
self-government
those were the two principles right it's
like when the Kingdom of Alexander broke
his kingdom divided not among four kings
as really among four generals and they
stayed separate mm-hmm and so there are
many different Kings among the four but
you
it's really talking about powers not a
particular king all the time but great
question mark I hope that helps a little
bit
thank you thank you and we do have a
study guide talks about America in
that's right it's called the u.s. in
Bible prophecy and we'll be happy to
share this with anyone who calls and ask
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and again you can answer the
amazing fact study guide is called the
u.s. in Bible prophecy and it's all
about Revelation chapter 13 the second
beast power we've got Ron listening in
Washington wrong welcome to the program
hi hi you know a little side note here
for me be talking about the Meissen yeah
you were aware that when you were that
when President Obama was in office he
named the Bison America's mammal no no
who who was in office that when that
happened President Obama oh he called
the the Bison America's unum Oh mammal
you know I didn't know I thought well I
kind of put your little pin in there
yeah that's a good one I need to look
that up get two horns like a lamb what
was your question tonight yeah oh okay
you got the New World Order the secret
rapture gumballanyah I'm really Miriam
and okay New World Order secret rapture
millennium really futurism and idealism
is there some way they all pack together
all right you know that yeah um well I
do think that the the ideas of futurism
idealism New World Order them probably
is some overlap because there's so many
people involved in those ideals that
they're they're probably some area of
connection there the the earth earth way
millennium now when we believe now
there's two views on the millennium one
one group of Christian the believes that
the righteous and the wicked are living
on earth together during the Millennium
another group believes that the
Millennium happens after the time of
trouble and the righteous are in heaven
and the wicked are destroyed wait
their judgment because he read in
revelation 20 the rest of the Dead the
wicked do not live until the thousand
years are finished
and so I'm in that second group as I
trust pastor Ross is that we live and
reign with Christ during the 1,000 years
and that's it's not on earth with these
ideals of the New World Order you know
we do have a book Ron that I think deals
with this thing in great detail it's a
great book I like the cover as well it's
called anything but secret it's talking
about the second coming of Christ
what happens after Jesus comes what
happens to the wicked and the righteous
I think you'll enjoy this read it's free
we'll send it anyone who calls and asks
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and again just asked for the book
it's called anything but secret and
we'll send it right out to you we have
Michael listening in Ontario Canada
Michael welcome to the program hello
well first off I just like to say thank
you Pastor Doug because back in 2012
when I was searching your videos that
led me to the Bible and I appreciate
that thank you very much praise the Lord
thank you Michael my question here is
has the the environment right there's a
there's a going around that the
environment will help in that be kind of
one of the arms that helped enact the
mark of the beast right international
mark of the beast and I just heard on
the radio today from a French blog that
that kovat 19 can actually carry in
pollution in which so that's how it can
also spread out is through pollution in
the air so do you think the real
question here is do you think that that
CO vid 19 this this right here that this
crisis is going to actually bring us
closer to that enactment of the mark of
the beast in which that they'll use the
environment as one of the arms to enact
it great question in a word yes I think
that I think what we've seen and it's
what you're asking is is it possible
that the environmental concerns will be
used as one of the reasons to make
religious laws and I do
one example of that would be and I
pastor Raza I did a program that's still
online now where we talk about the
sudden shift and I think I cited about
fifteen or sixteen different articles
from around the world where people are
saying look how this shutdown has helped
clean up the air and clean up the water
and people are spending more time with
their families and you have Jews and
Christians Catholics Protestants
atheists they're saying we need a day of
rest we need laws for a day of rest and
I could see them actually beginning to
campaign and legislate a international
day of rest for the environment
you know Greta was it Thornburg
Thornburg was you know she was
advocating that and so yeah I have no
doubt in my mind I saw another article
by a pastor this week that said the same
thing that God's trying to tell us we
need to get back to church and again
Michael if you haven't seen it you might
enjoy taking a look at it we just
recorded it about a week ago it's called
a second shift and I believe it's on the
Facebook page of amazing YouTube too
it's a standalone YouTube you don't have
you said we had two segments so it's
like two hours you may want to go to the
second hour to see this okay and I think
you'll find that interesting next
quarter that we have is Kathryn
listening from Washington State Kathryn
walking the program hello all right
Katherine you're on the air hi how are
you doing great considering good yeah
right and your question my question is
that I recently heard that Jesus
ministry was not three and a half years
but it was only 70 weeks and that was
based on Michael Rhodes Chronicle
chronological Gospels and I was just
wondering your thoughts on that well I
you know and with no disrespect intended
for Michael rude I'm sure he does a
great work I think if I'm not mistaken
he kind of specializes in work among the
Jews out of Israel but I I think the
Bible's pretty clear I think history is
pretty clear Jesus was baptized about 27
ad it tells us it was during the time of
Tiberius 15th year of the reign of
Tiberius it tells the pilot was in Judea
and Herod was in farad Philip was in the
Galilee area and it tells us there's
only one time in history when all of
those people were in power and it was 27
ad and it's pretty well-established
Roman date and that's when it says Luke
tells us when Jesus was baptized pastor
Ross I think looking at verse up and
then and we know when Jesus died he died
on the Passover three and a half years
later that would have been 31 ad and
then it was three-and-a-half years after
that when Stephen was stoned and a great
persecution arose Jesus was baptized on
his 30th birthday that's Luke chapter 3
the virtue referring to their about
Tiberius ceases Luke chapter 3 verse 1
says now in the fifteenth year of the
reign of Tiberius Caesar Pontius Pilate
being the governor in Judea Herod being
the Tetrarch in Galilee
he's brother Phillip in the tech tree
arc in UT Rhea and region of track
Aeneas and so we have a pretty solid
timeframe there and that is the baptism
of Jesus yeah it's like when you get a
GPS it'll you know I I used to be a
pilot I guess I still am a pilot I don't
flown lately but if you've got one
satellite you don't really know where
you are you get three satellites and you
can triangulate an exact point and we've
got four different dates here where
these kings their rules only overlap one
year and that's 27 so we know when when
Jesus was baptized we know when he died
and it's three and a half years and yeah
I hope that helps a little bit but thank
you for your question Katherine
we've got Becky listening in Grand Ledge
Michigan Becky welcome to the program
oh hi guys going doing good and your
question tonight uh
whew chapter 20 volt for verses three
through eight I need to know this
coronavirus is just a preload to the
Great Tribulation is coming up okay yeah
I don't know pastor Ross you want to
read couple of those verses yeah I'll
look in verse four here it says in jesus
answered and said to them take heed that
no one deceives you for many will come
in my name saying I am the Christ will
deceive many and you will hear of wars
rumors of wars see that you be not
troubled for all of these must come to
pass but the end is not yet
it says nation will rise against nation
Kingdom against Kingdom there will be
famines pestilences or diseases
earthquakes in various places this is
the beginning of Sorrows you know a lot
of pastors out there wondering is this
the beginning of Sorrows and I think it
was interesting even during our services
this weekend you know not only are we in
the midst of an international state of
emergency pandemic and then someone
emailed us a prayer requests help
there's another earthquake in Puerto
Rico and so you know we are seeing
earthquakes and we are seeing plagues as
Jesus foretold and so is this the
beginning of Sorrows and then what is
that the next verses there's going to be
a persecution for religious reasons they
will deliver you up to tribulation and
kill you you'll be hated now if there's
a major some kind of major international
earthquake following this major
international pandemic that'll be even
more compelling so but there have been
you know there have been global
pandemics we had one in 1918 I think it
reappeared in 1919 and there have been
major earthquakes Jesus said these are
some of the signs that that are going to
be happening between his first coming
and his second coming but you have to
come back to back on a global level
let be all the more reason to keep your
antenna up next koala that we have is a
Jasmine listening in California Jess I'm
walking to programs hello great and your
question tonight um I actually have a
question regarding the Gospel of John
chapter 8 okay me and my me and my
boyfriend were studying it and we have
been wondering on the part where it's
speaking of the Pharisees bringing the
woman who committed adultery to Jesus
and testing him regarding Moses's law
and saying how a person like that would
be required to be stoned we were curious
as to the significance of Jesus writing
on the ground and if there could be if
there's any hint within the Bible that
could point out what he possibly could
have wrote great question you know
Jazmin it doesn't say explicitly but
from the context as they continue
pressing the woman and they're accusing
her breaking one of the Ten Commandments
because all things were made were made
by Jesus that would mean that the Ten
Commandments he was there when they were
written and when Jesus now writes in the
temple they used to keep the Ten
Commandments in the temple when Jesus
writes in the temple I it maybe he was
writing the sins of her accusers they
looked down while they were getting
ready to throw stones at her and they
saw him writing their sins and then
Jesus says he that is without sin let
him cast the first stone
so it's good to know that Jesus writes
the law in stone but he writes our sins
in the dust it can be erased you know
pastor Doug is interesting you mentioned
that we find three times where God
writes you have God writing the Ten
Commandments and then you have God
writing on the wall in Belshazzar Palace
and that's judgment so you got the law
and then you have judgment and then you
find Jesus writing here in John chapter
8 and you see grace and forgiveness so
you have the law you have judgment for
breaking the law but for those who come
to Jesus they can obtain grace and mercy
as this woman did there in the temple of
course where do you find that mercy in
the temple in the presence of God so
it's quite a connection there does that
help Jasmin yeah yeah thank you so much
all right hey thank you good question
we've got Silvia listening in New York
Silvia welcome to the program hi guys hi
Doug Batchelor I watched every Sunday on
an amazing
facts well thank you so much you're
welcome appreciate your call my question
is this yes there is a time to die a
torn a time to mourn a time to laugh is
there a timeline on death now having
asked having asked you that I know that
God knows when we're going to die but is
there a timeline on that you know like
how people say well the person dies in
an accident was their time to die yeah I
think I know what you're saying is is
the person's their date of death kind of
pre-arranged by the Lord well you know I
think that god of course we've got if we
cooperate with all of God's laws and God
has mercy King David says the typical
lifespan is going to be threescore and
ten may be fourscore on an average
that's exactly what they have today
people live between 70 and 80 around the
world depends on your country lifestyle
if you're in Japan you might live to 86
but and it says you know the last few
years and these are averages you know
there's there's sorrow you don't want to
tempt the Lord and say well when my time
comes it comes and so you live
recklessly I think God blesses you with
longer life if you honor your father and
mother your days will be long upon the
land it take care of your health
do not tempt the Lord by doing things
that are reckless and you'll live longer
so yeah I eat I would not say well I
know that there's an international
pandemic out there but when my time
comes it won't matter so I'm I'm just
gonna expose myself needlessly to danger
I wouldn't use it that way
but you know does God know when we're
gonna die yeah cuz he knows everything
but he still lets us make decisions that
can lengthen our live or shorten our
lives does that make sense
carmen yeah yeah I'm sorry I didn't hear
you does that make sense Sylvia what
what I was saying about though you know
if we cooperate with God's laws it may
lengthen all but Mike
question is is our death predetermined
no I don't believe that just like I
don't believe your salvation is
predetermined I think God gives us a
will and Moses he several times says
obey these Commandments and you will
live disobey and you'll die and so we
can prolong our lives by cooperating
with God and of course we get eternal
life by accepting the salvation he's
offering but hey I hope that helps a
little bit and we're glad you're
watching Sylvia we're gonna try and
squeeze in one more call before our time
is up that is a predetermined time we
have a begun listening from Los Angeles
it go we have just a minute or two I
walk to the program hello thank you for
answering my question is regarding
isaiah 36 to 39 could you tell us please
if these chapters have a prophetic
interpretation in this yes who Assyrians
and King Hezekiah
are represent and what are the suit two
signs shown to the king okay Isaiah
chapter you want 36 through 39 well you
know it is gonna be difficult to read
three chapters in the time that we've
got left out of Isaiah but let me just
cover this very quickly I actually saw
this section of Scripture on the Dead
Sea Scrolls years ago and I know one of
the original Isaiah scrolls yeah I guess
you were there with me this a couple of
years ago pastor Ross this is an
incredible story where the the general
of Assyria our representative of Assyria
called the Rab shaka he was coming and
mocking God and saying the king of
Assyria was going to destroy Jerusalem
this is not just prophetic this is
historical this is exactly what happened
God told Hezekiah that the Assyrians
will not come here they're not going to
find a fight against the city they'll
not even fire an arrow and Hezekiah
prayed to the Lord and the people fasted
and they prayed he presented his case to
the Lord
the Bible says that Isaiah the prophet
came and assured him that God heard his
prayer and that night a hundred and
eighty-five thousand Assyrians died says
the mighty men among them and the Lord
also foretold that the king of Assyria
would be so embarrassed he would go back
to Assyria and he would die and by the
hand of his sons which is what happened
worshiping in the house of his God
showing that his God was powerless to
defend him even in his own temple and
yet Hezekiah with his little bitty army
in Jerusalem they were able to resist
and win against the mighty army of the
Assyrians at that time so it's a literal
chapter it's not simply prophetic and
I'm sure there are some number of
prophetic lessons in there now I hope
that I was answering what you're asking
Edgar but if if you don't mind giving us
a call next week if if I didn't get it
narrow it down to just a few verses we
try to budget two or three minutes for
each of our questions here maybe four
minutes don't think we're gonna read for
four chapters in Isaiah in in the time
we've got right now I'm in a holding
pattern because it's not quite enough
time for us to take another call but I
do want to mention that there's so much
that you can benefit from amazing facts
during this time when you're shut down
this program the live program is going
off the air in a few seconds but the
amazing facts website is available all
week long with hundreds of youtubes
Bible studies books that are free
download them watch them share them with
your friend and doing so you'll be
sharing Jesus and you'll be sharing life
and if you've been blessed keep us on
the air you know how that works you
click donate and God will bless you
thank you so much
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
book store calm written by the hand of
God and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore calm DT no amazing
backs has a free Bible school that you
can do from the comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 257,000 that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand four life-changing christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWE
- our online bookstore at AF bookstore
calm which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word to take advantage
of the offers you've heard on this
broadcast call us at
[Music]